Spider-Man across the spider-verse has
received rave reviews but some fans
aren't happy about one particular aspect
of the film it goes without saying that
Spider-Man across the spider verse one
of the most anticipated films of 2023
it's a follow-up to the oscar-winning
Spider-Man into the spider-verse that's
been five years in the making it has
quite a legacy to live up to and if
reviews are any indication as Soaring
Over most people's expectations the
animation is top-notch and it takes the
characters in a darker more mature
Direction with a plot that places the
fate of the entire Multiverse at stake
however it appears as at least one thing
that's dampening people's enjoyments of
the film and theaters numerous online
threads of emerged so viewers discussing
how the sound mix felt off at least at
the beginning of the movie in the
official across the spider-verse
discussion thread on Reddit many people
chimed in implying this as a nationwide
issue that isn't localized to just a
couple of theaters for instance one
ready to Rose did anyone else's theater
have sound mixing two low for characters
compared to the music other than that
this movie was an absolute treat
her name's Miles Morales I'm Spiderman
other people chimed in saying they
noticed it during the opening sequence
which featured a voiceover from Gwen
Stacy while rhythmic drumming plays
apparently the music's so loud is
difficult to make out anything Gwen says
to the point where people are already
looking forward to the home release so
that they can rewatch the scene with
subtitles Reddit isn't the only place
where Spidey fans are voicing their
frustration similar comments have
emerged on Twitter as well as a threat
on reset era and it would appear the
people behind the movie have become well
aware of the situation across the
spider-verse writer and producer Phil
Lord tweeted some pictures of stickers
he had made up to Center movie theater
projectionists that read I played
spider-verse at full volume because I'm
awesome he went on to explain the movie
mix is really Dynamic and comfortable at
full volume in a full house it might
even be better at 7.5 it would appear
that everyone has received the memo yet
as plenty of people commented underneath
Lord's pose to talk about their audio
mix issues the common complaint is that
the dialogue is too quiet when the film
starts and gets drowned out by the music
and it seems to be a recurring issue
regardless of what format people see it
in
okay some theater employees mentioned
how they would abide by Lord's
guidelines but it may take others time
to receive word that means fans who saw
it last night may have had issues with
the film that those who plan on seeing
it in a week or two won't experience not
being able to hear what Gwen's saying at
the beginning of across the spider-verse
can be cumbersome but as clear most fans
love this movie regardless the film
currently has a 95 positive rating from
critics and rotten tomatoes and people
can't stop raving about it on Twitter
under Phil Lord's tweet fans discuss
their personal experiences with the
audio mix but many were quick to remind
him that the film is fantastic one
person even tweeted it was too quiet in
my theater tonight guess I'll have to go
see it again and again and again on top
of that the film is such a visual
spectacle that even scenes of just two
characters talking are incredibly fun to
watch it makes sense for a people who
pointed out the audio issues but also
argued that they came secondary to
everything else one person wrote on
Reddit eventually I stopped paying
attention to that because the movie
sucked me in hopefully projectionists
get a word of the best settings to use
for the film's audio but if they don't
it seems like people will still have a
good time Spider-Man across the spider
verse as playing in theaters right now
foreign